hey everybody a miles I'm here with
charles murray author of prevention get
firm and lean and eight men wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh this is not
that's not my book oh no I'm sorry there
we go now you think yes it's so easy to
confuse the two
they easily get mixed up this is the
do's and don'ts of right behavior tough
thinking clear writing and living a good
life and this is a really good book for
people that are just coming out of
college and trying to find their way in
the workforce it's it's really
treacherous you know that that
transition from college to the workforce
first place because a lot of a lot of
people are having their first real jobs
right you know they've they've had
internships and things like that but
they've never really been in a workplace
and they don't know how that operates I
am some of the others are going directly
to graduate school and why are they
going to graduate school because they
know how to function in the academic
environment and it's the line of least
resistance and they lock themselves into
a profession evade so so they need us
reading together exactly they need to
read the commission's guide can I'm
going to tell them all sorts of things
that actually in some cases are a lot
more fun than what their parents are
telling them to do for example I tell
them don't go to graduate school get a
one-way airplane ticket to someplace
really weird get off the plane get a job
and live there for three years now
that's more fun it doesn't that's more
fun excursion school you have a lot of
great advice in here though because a
lot of these people get a job and their
boss might be somebody who's a bit older
than them and it's there's generally
like closeted curmudgeon right that's
that's the sneaky part because we have
gotten so wheat meaning geezers like me
we're so sensitive about appearing to be
old we don't want to we don't want to
let go we don't want to look out of date
so we don't tell you what we're thinking
right we even act as if we're nice guys
but deep inside we're making all these
judgments about you on the basis of some
very grumpy views of modern culture and
you want to know that so what should we
do so as not to cross you unwittingly
perhaps okay here's the number one thing
do not you
the word like several times in a given
sentence yeah I want to tell you if I'm
hiring somebody and the job interview
they say you know well like I went to
like Dartmouth for three or four like
yeah I'm sort of saying to myself if
this guy gets hired by some miracle I
sure hope I don't have to deal with this
right oh that's one thing that would be
like so annoying like so annoying and
and showing up with a tattoo that's
visible mm-hmm no I know this is this is
really unfair I know the tattoos are new
art form I understand all that yeah
people should have gotten them out of
their system I gotta tell you that every
time I see a tattoo I say when that
person is 60 years old what's that
tattoo gonna look like and I'm also
identifying the tattoo as you know that
that's sort of a badge of the Lord class
isn't it see I'm a geezer it's not fair
I understand it's not fair but but it's
out there so why make trouble for
yourself what about piercing so it's
marine fauna if it's a woman's ear lobe
Pierce so she can have a lovely earring
dangling from it it's great through the
eyebrow not not so much what about like
a nipple through a shirt you can see
I've man or woman I forgot I forgot to
put that in the pit
no and then definitely no all right and
what about dressing like a 70s car
salesman well here's a problem because
you can't trust your fellows of your own
age group to know what the office
unspoken dress code is like so here's
you look at people who are more senior
positions how do they dress you may not
like the way they dress probably you're
best off to be within their ballpark
seems pretty fair well I think that's a
good start for the rest of it you should
definitely pick up the curmudgeons guide
to getting ahead and while you're at it
maybe grab a slice of prevention get
firmly animate listen I could use that
one good alright thank you so much mr.
Marr my pleasure and you didn't call me
Chuck I read your book